the origins of st. Patrick I started
with a man named Niall of the Nine
Hostages who was an Irish pirate and
went about the British Isles capturing
people and bringing them back and
selling them as slaves so he went to
we're not sure whether he went to Wales
where he captured this man Patrick and
brought him back and sold him to a man
named milk ooh and Patrick was put out
in the hills of County Antrim to serve
as a shepherd for about four or five
years he was a teenager when he was
captured and that's not a real name
Patrick there was not his name he was
from a patrician Roman family and
therefore he was known as the patrician
so when they wanted him to empty the
slop pockets or something like that to
say let the patrician do it so that's
how he got the name Patrick so anyway
I'm not sure what he's affection for
Ireland was a great wonderful poetic
litoris pagan country and it had bards
and druids in the ascendancy and he
thought that they should all be
converted to Christianity so when he
escaped subsequently he went to France
to his uncle san martin of tours and
then he went to rome and he was
consecrated a bishop and then made his
way back to Ireland for 32 and ruined a
perfectly good civilization
well he became he used the Shamrock
which is three leaves as the metaphor
for the Trinity of that belief you know
God the Father God the Son God the Holy
Ghost and so he held that up and in one
stem he used that as his illustration
and of course the Shamrock been green it
be token Green has been something but
his own color was blue and st. Patrick's
blue was is well known over the years it
was a day of holy day of obligation in
Ireland very little celebration my
memories of it are of a gloomy rainy
awful day when no matter what we had to
get up an hour earlier and go to Mass
and then go to school and face the same
old rubbish from being hit on the head
or beaten on the hands by because
corporal punishment was in order at the
time and I think it still is to us at
least that so it didn't change much but
then what happened over the years as it
became a holiday a big holiday here in
our a big celebration i should say
another holiday a celebration here in
New York tre said oh oh we should do
something about that so they decided to
imitate what it goes on here everything
except that the crowd here are somewhat
and not somewhat quite a homophobic and
they don't let the gays march as a unit
as an identified unit whereas in Ireland
the home of the whole bloody thing is
the gay people get they get prizes and
awards for being the most colorful group
in parades so I think it's amazing
the when when we move we move we went to
Ireland because of the death death of my
little sister and there were my brother
Frank myself and twin boys Oliver a new
gene and when we got to Ireland we were
to within two years the two boys Eugene
and Oliver died when they were about
four and four and a half of various
ailments at the time that nobody cared
too much about what was going on with
poor people there were no autopsies or
anything he just died him he just died
and good riddance but but when we got
there childre was three and a half Frank
was born uh we were known as Yanks and
you feel outside the tribe when you are
speaking differently acting differently
behaving differently so as quickly as
possible you made the attempt to be get
in with the gang talk like them and be
like them and dressed like them so but
no no matter what we did we were still
Yanks so then we grow up there and we
come to America back to America back to
know here and they say oh you're Irish
over there we Yanks over here were Irish
so my brother Frank and myself decided a
long time ago that what we are very
simply is we are New Yorkers this is our
country this is my land this is the
place for me where every single dream I
ever had came to fruition and I love it
dearly I love yellow York
to be Irish in 2010 2010 there's a there
is a pride in our that that's happened
in our intellectual accomplishments and
our literary compliments can accomplish
with in our technological
accomplishments but here the four after
oh eight hundred years of occupation and
the function of the oppressor is to
assure you that you are nothing that
you're nobody that you're less than
deserving of nothing that you are a
piece of and don't aspire to
anything and they infuse you with with
shame which has to do with the past
because the all shame is based firmly in
the past it has to do with what you have
done what you thought you have done and
what has sometimes shame is induced by
what has been done to you and by
allowing things to be done to you you're
ashamed of not resisting so that's one
part of oppression is to make sure you
make sure you're a shameful shamed human
being then on the other end that takes
care of the past and the future has to
do with fear don't attempt to come up
here don't attempt to go forward you are
you were nobody you are nobody and
you'll always be nothing so don't even
think about coming here because if you
do something awful will happen to you so
we were we were cut between the two
demons to devil
shame and fear and we couldn't deal with
the present which was that we are indeed
as accomplished in our own minds as
spiritual as any other people as good as
any other people but we could not look
in the mirror and ever say that that's
that's what we are so to be Irish today
is the abandonment of that shame and the
younger people are moving it out and
they're moving the fear away they're not
afraid their adventurous they're going
about the world as careful look carefree
were carefree I suppose but as with
confidence I'm with them there with the
knowledge of the language with the
education linguistically capable poetic
and fun-loving with a love of song and
of life itself so that for the younger
people to me is it is a great it's a
wonderful thing that is happening the
older ones of my generation are infused
with fit they still have the fear and
various ethnic groups have have diseases
that are peculiar to their group and for
example Jewish people have a sax and the
African Americans have a sickle cell
anemia and the the Irish diseases
respectability and that infects and them
a lot and there was what would somebody
say law was what would they say what
would the English say if you wore that
said that bead that so consequently as
the Irish poet he said you eventually
become the thing you hate the most
that's why so many of these yahoos
particularly the ones that run the
center st. Patrick's Day parade are
conservatives and that conservatism is
is not a political ideology it is a form
a severe form of brain damage from which
there's hardly any cure I don't know
what what we can do with them as a whole
but they are gradually moving out the
younger folks are taken over and someday
there may be some culture in this st.
Patrick's Day but I prefer if it were an
Irish parade like Israel Israel has a as
a parade that's Israel not devoted to
Moses or Abraham or said Moses of st.
Abraham and so I'd like to see the day
when this was an Irish play because you
can't be grand marshal of this charade
if you're not a Catholic and they say a
practicing Catholic now a lot of these
guys are hypocrites I've been there
about Dara borders practicing as as I am
and I don't certainly am NOT I observe
the whole thing myself but they are it's
hypocritical anyway and I hope that one
day it will be an Ireland would be nice
parade then I would March future if you
have if you have one foot in the future
I one foot in the past you're pissing on
the present so I stay in the present so
I don't know about the future
it has to do I think with possibly now
III am full of theories which are based
on a very liquid foundation because I
used to be a drinker but the culture
before st. Patrick came there were six
invasions of Ireland and I can't think
of who they were there were tribes tutor
d Donna and the Milesians and the Celts
and they brought their languages with
them and someone other than melded into
whatever was there then and then the
Celts came bringing their language with
them then sympatric am bringing Latin
with him then there was the invasions
the constant divisions of the of the
Vikings bring the North's languages with
them then Henry the second sent over
these Norman's bringing French language
in there and then the English themselves
came bringing English so here all these
languages and instead of the Irish
learning their language they all learned
whatever was was spoken there so
consequently there's a huge availability
of worlds and because we had nothing
else to do when I am speaking we because
we were poverty-stricken we rely totally
on the word and biblically the word is
you're in the big the Bible it says you
know in the beginning was the word and
I'm not a religious man at all but if
the Bible says yeah I agree with that
part of it anyway in the B and the word
is a sound of some sort and that's what
the energy comes from so I like that so
the Irish because they had nothing else
to do they used language and glorious
charms and when an Englishman speaks
well for example down this is another
way of putting us down they say he's
eloquent to their arrow eloquent SAT
there
for a block Irish person speaks well
they say and you have the gift of the
gab are you kissed the Blarney Stone see
always putting a stone now if you look
up the word gap in the dictionary order
it's insignificant importance of no
substance that's what gab is if that's a
gift they can shove it up their armpit
as far as I'm concerned because I
certainly don't want it so we then
listening listening to people talking
telling stories and everything has to be
a story every every experience coming
here today is an experience and you can
make a story just about out of anything
I and it has nothing to do with the hash
pneus of a formal education which I
don't have because I I failed everything
in school I left when I was was 13
because I had no comprehension what the
hell they were talking about up there at
the blackboard it was all I must have
that a DD thing but listening to people
i said that's wonderful to be able to
tell a story and somebody once said that
the Irish derived the greatest benefits
from the English language they caught it
like a beautiful woman they make a Bray
with donkey laughter they fling it with
the sky like paint pots full of rainbow
colors then they make a chanted dirge of
man's fate of man's follies like a soft
rain falling over the burn that they
have paid the oppressor the supreme
compliment of taking his language and
turning it to sorcery I say yeah that's
what we do with it that's the one thing
the English left us and I love it
never clean a window with a soft-boiled
egg do I have a favorite Irish proverb
well speaking of well I thought is
saying that I like is you know what to
talk about Saints in st. Patrick and all
that I I have no time for that that kind
of thing but to be a saint is a severely
edited sinner that's what I that's what
I think
hello actually limericks don't come from
Limerick you know but it comes from that
between the verses when they used to
have those competitions that they would
put in the refrain follow me up follow
me up follow me up to Limerick town you
know there was a young lady from tres
who's corsets were to title lace her
mother said Delhi there's more than your
belly they never went in through your
face my favorite job I were my purpose
in life always has been to avoid work
you know I hear these people saying I
work hard and I pay my taxes when you're
an asshole because in my readings if the
Bible is correct and I'm not a biblical
scholar by any means but whatever adam
and eve did I don't know what it was but
they did something that apparently
annoyed the guy that made them and they
got booted and she was sentenced to bear
children and pain and labor which and
they didn't mention they will have to
grow up to be teenagers and he was
sentenced to work in the fields where
his skin would be burnt by the Sun and
his hands will be torn by the thorns and
thistles of the field and he should earn
his bread by the sweat of his brow so
that to me is work you see so I always
have I didn't do it he did so let him
pay the price more my sins that's called
original sin all mine are mine and all
my sins are original so I've avoided
work all my life you see so I'm like a
I'm like a bee I go from flower to
flower I go where the nectar is and then
we make life just a lot of money so
whenever I'm broadcasting I like it when
I'm writing but I'm broadcasting I can't
wait to hear what
I have to say when I'm writing I
thoroughly enjoyed it just goes off I
write in longhand and just goes on and
on and on when I was in the saloon
business I just would greet people and
talk to them and avoid taxes and getting
behind the bar what else I ran for
governor of New York and I thoroughly
enjoyed campaigning I don't know that
mostly anything to do with socializing
entertaining having a chat there is
nothing like it and I'm curious to know
what's over the other cyber because
people people don't know but the thing
is that people don't die here you see in
America they they pass away they pass on
the levers they're gone no longer with
us they're at peace there with the Lord
the six feet under earth of kicked the
bucket and and the other thing is they
don't allow a dying on the you nobody
ever says that they don't allow even on
the highway they won't allow you to die
I answered no passing to give you a
ticket if you die in the highway
I would say I'm more spiritual than I
see the way I look upon organized
religion organized religion I'm of the
victim of that you know mythology & of
cruelty and of absurd stuff and
organized religion has all the facets of
organized crime except the compassion of
organized crime they will only break
your legs whereas organized religion
will send you to hell forever and we
have to think about all that stuff of
snakes and paradise and even you know
making the connection between why the
guy who ever was made these Adam and Eve
and makes all of these animals all the
cows and sheep and pigs and elephants
and rhinoceroses and rabbits and hares
and moles and octopuses and salmon and
trout and and snakes and of all the
animals that he or she would ever
created he brings one into paradise the
snake now you think you'd bring a nice
little dog or a poodle or something at
the paradise to keep Adam and Eve
company know a bloody snake instead of a
cat maybe you just didn't that would
have been no snake not alone that for a
talking snake who said how I leave how
I'm fine thank you how about this Apple
oh really oh let me try Oh in Adam this
is great apple so she hands him the
Apple and they get tossed out and he has
to go and work she has to bear children
and the snake they say he has to crawl
on his belly for all eternity and eat
dust now if he was a serpent before how
did he get around
so they banished him and tossed him out
and sent into Ireland and then they say
st. Patrick came and banished all the
snakes from Ireland so he might have
because I think they all came here and
took over the sim patrick's day parade
that's my idea
well I I am an alcoholic as I said and
and it is however we caught a disease
that's an explanation but not an excuse
so once I know I'm an alcoholic than it
is by mountain obligation duty to see
what I can do about healing myself now
there's no recovery from alcoholism it
is an incurable disease and it also is a
disease which tells you you don't have a
disease it tells you I am your friend
and all you need at any given time is it
a drinky-poo to make life good and all
of that so then you take the little
drinky-poo and the next thing you know
you have consumed about 40 drinky poos
and you're acting like the complete
asshole that you were before you had the
drinky poo so ah i discovered that and I
said I would never I would never become
an alcoholic like my father because my
father deserted us but diseases they
don't there's no let-up they get you
some way or another so the alcoholism
got me and I ruined my first marriage
with drinking and the lying deceit
infidelity and all of that the whole
bloody thing there was I was the
complete one alienated my first wife and
although I never I was not abusive in
the physical sense in that I did never
never helps what hit her like many I'm I
was lucky that I'm not addicted to that
kind of thing but I also alienated my
children that much i'm uncle terms with
him now and i've been married for 45
years to my second wife I've been sober
for 25 and every day I am very grateful
that I am that I don't drink
and it's one day at a time that's all
there is to it and I so I don't have to
worry about it all I do is okay i don't
i do not have to drink and if i feel
like it i postponed it for 10 minutes
and in that way I'll find something else
to do in the meantime but alcoholism is
a dread and awful and fatal disease and
I've seen so many horrible awful results
and consequences of people practicing
alcoholism it's murder I've seen that
I've seen a lot of suicides a lot of
strange sin septic Lee you get a lot of
thievery and the whole thing is involved
the lying there we were great were liars
and then a lot of people abuse their
children and more than hitting so many
people abuse their children sexually as
well and that is that's that that's it
is a family disease and that's one of
the horrors of it when kids are abused
sexually and the seems to be more of it
now than ever and I find that I find
that so sad that that happens
Patterson walking into a the governor of
new york at the moment walked into a
mess and a national and international
mess and he's he's lost and he's having
a rough time I when I ran for governor
and I was up in Syracuse in a report to
ask me what would you do if you're
elected I said well I would change the
name of the state and he said why is
that I said well I don't I don't like
the name Empire State it resonates of
colonial times you see I don't want to
be Emperor I want to be governor and
then why later the governor Spitzer was
caught in that compromising situation
with the ladies and the name of the club
that supplied the girls was the
Emperor's Club so I didn't realize that
I was being so prescient at the time but
i think that the they're such a our
people are so disillusioned with the
parties it's one party with two
different names and they are so
spineless and i had great faith that
perhaps this man Obama would do
something but he is they're all in the
grip of big money and unless we have
unless we can do away with that where we
are done and the Supreme Court gives
corporations the same rights as as human
being it's absurd you can't do that
corporations can deduct their planes all
their office expenses their machinery
computers and teleprompters or whatever
else they have they can deduct their
yachts they can deduct their limousines
their planes everything now here are my
you
being and that that has a body that is
getting old and I only have one I can't
trade it in like they can get a new
plane or a new limousine or a new yard I
they won't give me a new body but I
can't today deduct my heart or my lungs
are further I'd like to deduct my
falling hair but now they won't let me
do that there yet the corporations can
do that so it's not fair
the Green Party asked me and I was I
thought I am utterly free of of any kind
of I mean not more my skin i wrote my
scandals by whatever my book in my book
among swimming and singing my hem song
so all my life is fairly well and my
brother Frank wrote about her life so
it's all pretty much out in the open
what our lives so there was no scandal
involved there and it's I'm an alcoholic
recovering and I used to smoke
cigarettes and I was a philanderer and
not why wouldn't call myself a goodbye
says i said i am i'm on the lines of a
sinner and I want to be known as that so
I could I could that an over in in the
British Isles and Ireland people stand
for office I had over here the run we
know why so I decided I would stand for
office here and so it was see if i get
the 50,000 votes for the party and a
strange thing happened all my running
mates who were less well-known than I
all got over the 50,000 somehow or
another I didn't and so we suspect there
was chicken Ritu keep the party from
getting the 50,000 volts so maybe I'll
do it again
it's a it's a no it's an organic thing
really that you if you don't read if you
and that's kids are not reading much
these days and if you don't and we are
getting higher insensitive to to human
suffering because we can't distinguish
what happens on the screen between that
which is simulated violence and rape and
murder from that which is real so such
hard till to to to stimulate people to
to get it to get involved yet is that
when you give people a direct then what
is happy and here's what I'm trying to
get this straightened by my own head the
purpose of the media is to make us all
spectators not to watch so that's why we
have in millions of fat children
watching games eating and consuming and
and not playing themselves that's the
unfortunate thing that's happening so we
are spectators to violence and therefore
well we don't know and make sure that we
don't know the difference the real
violence and that the simulation so keep
us keep us out of it and that way do you
have corporate control does that make
sense
I tell my children shut up let me speak
what I've learned I have been married
for 45 years and on a on my own on my
own family it is this that I've learned
to stop being judgmental to listen and I
tell Diana my wife every morning that I
love her and that's about and that's
very difficult for an Irish man because
you never see the palms of Irish
people's hands were always closed you
see whereas Mediterranean people Jewish
people and other ethnic groups you see
the pound not the Irish oh no just watch
him so anyway democracy to me is letting
the other person speak and being being
dissenting without being disagreeable
that's perfectly all right email and all
and to make sure that we don't that
never never disappoint a child just say
I am because my child was so filled with
disappointment that I did the scars of
it or are still there and I mean you can
do you can you can't give them
everything but don't promise something
that you're not going to fulfill and so
and to always make sure that a child's
self-esteem is at the proper level
without me know when you're bullshitting
them you see but if you say I like what
you did with that problem you can deal
with that but not say I think you're
Einstein that's you see
to lose one parent is a tragedy to lose
both his utter carelessness so it's a
euphemism and he died Frank died in July
and he wrote he wrote Angela's Ashes in
1996 and he had just retired here or so
before from a teaching of the New York
City High School System and always knew
he was a good writer or a wonderful
writer and I arched him for years to do
to write Angeles to write a book not I
didn't know what he was going to call it
we were very good friends we wrote a
play together called a couple of
legguards which we performed we talked
to each other on a daily basis and he
was when my father left although Frank
was only ten he actually took over them
as the the paterfamilias the father of
the family and he was court looked after
us all even though I was only a year a
month and a day younger where I always
thought he was smaller than me but he
was the only smaller person that I ever
looked up to and all his life and so he
was a good friend decent guy great sense
of humor extraordinary intellect and
loved passing on his knowledge um all he
students adored him because he had the
advantage of having no formal education
in the sense that he did have he left
school like I did in the age of 13 and
he went back when he was 22 and some or
another faked his way into New York
University and got himself a degree
after being on probation and then became
a teacher so he wasn't circumscribed by
by ordinary thinking
about teaching his if a teacher loves
what she is teaching or he is teaching
is the case may be then you again you
passed along the love of it rather than
punish me you are or you have a test
this mother always doing with children
testing no children don't need testing
they need loving and that was Frank's
idea love them though of what you're
talking about love the words there was
an Irish poet named John Millington
Synge said words particularly in a play
should have the texture of a crisp
autumn apple that's the way I think of
it I think that's the way Frank thought
about it too
yeah at having there was a department in
where we grew up having a father dessert
you was shameful so you felt ashamed and
not having a father other kids talked
about their fathers and their father
supported them their fathers looked
after them and their father stood up for
them and we we had nobody ever to do
that for us and so now here's the odd
thing about not odd but being alcoholic
I was not a good father in my first
marriage I was about his although
there's ways of deserting a family
without leaving physically I was
deserted in my head so I was always out
it was always in the saloons always
drinking always messing about but when I
was at the kids I was pretty pretty let
me know what they all said they enjoyed
me that's what it was because being a
kid myself I love playing and I love
playing with words and making up things
and riddles and songs and Bing and not
afraid of being silly in public so they
like that but it wasn't being really
being a father so that was and then when
I we divorced I mean it was the
visitation stuff but I think and the
second marriage we have two kids and I'm
a stepdaughter and then the other two I
i I'm sort of cemented relationships
with my kids on the first marriage so
now I get along more than get along we
have a good relationship with all of
them and they're our grandchildren and I
think they think well of me I hope they
do anywhere and if they don't well of
course I'm nothing I can do about it but
won't be with the one for trying
there are I think that 45 years old that
people are apt to start thinking we're
almost the same MO blah blah but I am
constantly astounded at Diana's mind
which is a wonderful intellect and I
love to hear what she has to say and we
never run out of things to talk about
the other is that the actual thing of
saying I love you which I do every
morning is extremely important and that
immediately starts the day with a bit of
a smile no matter what and if you're in
the middle of a disagreement which all
couples have you could come up with
something like have you ever thought of
the era erotic capabilities of a parsnip
you get a laugh you see ah the other
thing is that i find that we have
unspoken agreements which are that we
don't say you never never said that are
you always never say that and never make
any reference to the other person's
family you're just like your because
that is that's that is out completely
and what else that's about that that
kind of keeps things on an even keel
most of the time I Anna I like her as
well it's a great friend so that's my
marriage anyway and loving keep loving
that's all there is to it mean we hug we
kiss and make love and it's great
well it's a it's much faster now than
life is much faster people get past me
quicker that when I when I first came
there's it economically it's it's it's
been up and down in the 55 years that
that I have been here there's the I
absolutely love the the public
transportation system in New York it's
no matter what about how people complain
it is the best in the world I like the
police force they're very they've seen
everything you know it's a the others 47
people up there on the roof and the
throwing tomatoes yes sir thank you they
don't get excited like I don't have to
get out machine guns any other places
there seems to be less bless obvious
corruption and the in city government I
know re New York politicians they're not
Republican or Democrat the New Yorkers I
like that and New York people are
generally speaking pretty pretty helpful
and courteous despite the fact that says
you know you don't supposed to be rude
and all that kind of Business Times
Square has man I kind of missed the old
some sleazy Times Square in a way and
yet I don't mind not being accosted by
you know vol Sultan strange people
what keeps me up Jon Stewart and the
daily show that that why I thoroughly
enjoy that show for the other is I I
wonder I I wonder what I can do about
war it's such a is it the destiny of
humankind to eventually wipe ourselves
out with these weapons of mass
destruction are we stupid to think that
we can control them if they said well we
only have 2500 atomic weapons or neutron
neutron bombs what differences make we
have one or two thousand five hundred
there the damage will be just the same
there's overkill there and I would like
to to I would like to do away with all
kinds of all weapons a dream totally
including the bow and arrow
ah i think when i was a kid that i was
advised that the and this is poverty
depression thinking somebody said there
was a there was a job in limerick where
I grew up and at the time cars were not
as as numerous as they are now there
were more horses and so they dumped
their their horse all over the
place and there was a few people got
jobs in Limerick a big barrel on wheels
it was a battle went back and forth and
a shovel and a broom so they went around
shoveling the horse into this into
this barrel so you got that job when
you're about 15 and then you've got to
retire at the age of 65 with the pension
small pension so that would be 50 years
of shoveling horse and I was
advised very seriously that I should get
that job and take heart that now that's
it that's either here on this earth
shoveling horse or else it's my
punishment in hell shoveling horse
and that's the worst advice I ever got
and the best advice was to whatever you
want cuz that's not what you are that's
what you do for the moment
you